we're now going to look at the chapter
four
which is on methods for clustering
actually we haven't done that much in
the course so far we've just seen
vectors some examples we know just a
handful of operations on them
for example we can look at the norm
which is a measure of
size we can look at distance between two
vectors and in fact that's where we take
off from
in the idea of clustering but we'll find
that even just with
this extremely small list of things we
know about
in fact in this case specifically only
simply the distance between two vectors
we can already do interesting and useful
things
so uh in some sense this is just a
a detour out of the main topic of the
course but it's just to show you that
even with these
an extremely small list of things you
know about we can actually do
cool and useful stuff you can use this
at your next internship by the way
and if people don't know about it
they'll be very impressed okay
so the idea behind clustering is this um
we start with a whole bunch of n vectors
we have capital n and vectors and we're
going to call them x1 through xn
that's a subscript notice this is a
little ambiguous right
because x7 is actually a vector
it is the seventh vector in our list of
vectors right so
if you wanted to refer to a component of
x7 for example you might do this
and that would be this would in this
thing here
that notation would indicate x7 is the
seventh vector
this is a number now uh it's the fifth
entry
of the seventh vector okay so i have a
list of vectors
and the goal is to take these capital n
vectors
and divide or cluster them into part
it's
either partitions groups subsets however
you want to say it
so for example we might want to divide
them into
three or five um uh by convention
uh actually because of that you know
that that's a long history uh
we're going to call the number of groups
that we partition the vectors into
k okay so here's the idea
the idea is you want to make these
partitions
of vectors you want to group them into
groups that are close to each other and
so down here we're going to see a
picture
here's our actual data now in this case
these are vectors in these are two
vectors right so we can plot them
of course we're not that interested in
clustering two vectors right we're much
more interested in
clustering 10 vectors 10 000 vectors or
even a million vectors right
million vectors and i don't know how
many we've got here maybe
100 couple hundred it really doesn't
matter but you can see them here
now your eyeball tells you right away
that you know you could cluster them
into like kind of three groups
like that okay uh that's just your
eyeball of course your eyeball is not
going to work when you have vectors
of dimension ten thousand right so but
here
and it's a it's a it's kind of grow like
you know there's some
question as to which cluster does the
ones like near the
between two lie in uh but these are like
detailed the idea is just a as a rough
idea to
you get three groups here okay so here's
an example of a clustering and what
we've done is we have color code
we've had k equal we have k equals three
here and we've color coded them
so you can see which of the uh
which of the vectors over here have been
assigned to which group and so we have a
green group
a red group and a blue group okay and
you know you could quibble with some of
our choices here like for example
i don't know if you can see but there's
a little green dot right there and you
might say oh no that one should be red
you know you're you know these are uh
this is minor it's it's not a it's not a
very precise concept it's just
and we'll see that in applications it'll
be clear that it's not a very precise
concept but we'll see also it's
unbelievably useful
okay so this is the idea so the question
is how do we automatically
uh come up with a clustering uh like the
one shown here um
i should add that if we're doing this if
we're doing this for vectors that are
in um that have dimension two you use
your eyeball to do the clustering you
get out a pencil
and you cluster them just like i did
over here that's exactly what that's
manual clustering that's not going to
cut it
in higher dimensions okay
so before we talk about how to do it i
want to talk about what you might
use it for what would you use clustering
for or what would be the setting in
which you would use clustering
well it's actually super interesting so
here's an example let's suppose
that the vectors are word count
histograms for a collection of documents
some people call a collection of
documents a corpus so for example
wikipedia is sometimes considered
a corpus right i forget how many uh
documents well it's changing every day
are in wikipedia but that's a corpus of
documents right and then for each
document
you would have uh a word count histogram
that just counts the number of words
so um you know it it's it's very
unsophisticated um you know i want to
add that that means that
when we associate a vector with each
document
it is really profoundly stupid it does
not it does not understand english it
does not
understand syntax it doesn't know what a
sentence is it doesn't know what a
paragraph is
it has absolutely no meaning what any of
the words are it simply counts the words
in our dictionary and that's our vector
okay so i just emphasize how crude how
crude uh this really is
uh and yet we'll see it's pretty
shocking what happens okay
here would be another potential area
where you might do this
is let's go back let's do patient
clustering so
let's have a large hospital or network
of hospitals and we
what we do is each vector is going to
represent one patient and
what it's going to have the entries are
going to things are going to encode
things like
age sex weight height
blood pressure diastolic systolic
whether or not they're currently
experiencing chest pain
it could give the the vector could also
have entries
that tell you that encode whether not
just symptoms
but also the results of tests right have
they tested negative for something or
positive for something so that would be
or if it's a numerical test
uh it could that i mean that that's also
that would be encoded in x okay so these
are
your vectors your is is is actually a
set of attributes
of each patient okay now
there um it would be very useful if you
had
a hundred thousand patients to group
them into i don't know
i'm not making this up but you know 60
different clusters and you could
probably find out some interesting stuff
that way
okay customer market segmentation so
this is
uh as a matter of fact this is done
pretty much universally
and the way that works is that each each
vector corresponds
are a set of attributes that correspond
to
a customer and so what you do is it
would include things like their purchase
history
how many dollars over the last month uh
of
item such and such have they have they
purchased right that's an example
it could include others other attributes
of a uh
it could include like where they live
age group
education level i mean any of all of
these are possible right so we can
that's the idea and now what you do is
uh you would cluster these vectors right
so um
and the idea is we would get i don't
know 68
groups of clusters um and
uh groups or clusters of customers and
then a person would
get their eyeball in there and go in and
look and they'd say oh i
see what this is this these are you know
these are 18 to 22 year old college
students or something i don't know that
kind of thing
okay so uh there this there
this would be quite useful right because
you could then tune your marketing and
other stuff advertising okay
um here's a here's an application it's
actually one of the
uh it's a famous one that people you
know typically show
uh all the time um and it's uh color
compression of images
right so an an image uh
here what you do is you have an image
and what you do is you think of each of
its pixels
so you might have 4 million pixels right
in the 4k by 1k
image you have 4 million pixels each
pixel is a 3 vector
which give you the r g and b that's red
green and blue
intensity right um now for historical
reasons
those go between zero and 255 but
we'll just call them between zero and
one i mean it actually doesn't it's not
going to make any difference
it's just a three vector right ok so
if you cluster 3 vectors it's actually
super duper interesting right so you can
actually cluster
cluster the number of different colors
to maybe 100 um by the way
that's not that many right because these
are three vectors
but you know once you get a hundred you
you actually
images uh that way and then the
advantage of course is you don't have to
give three real numbers for every pixel
you just say oh that's cluster number 45
that one
is cluster number 66 or something like
that so that that's kind of the idea
that's used for compression
because you can say you can describe
an image way faster if you have only 100
different colors
okay here's another example is in
in finance so each vector corresponds to
a company
and my vector includes attributes of
that company
it could be for example the return of
their stock last month
last year could have both of them it
could be their total capitalization
it could be their price to earnings
ratio it could we could encode the
sector they're in right so for example
if there
we could have a we could have a feature
that's either zero if you're not in the
energy sector and one
if you're in the energy sector these are
examples um
okay so this would be uh this so the
vectors correspond to
uh companies basically um
and now uh what would happen is we would
take uh
these vectors it might be ten thousand
of them fifteen thousand
thirty thousand and they might have each
i don't know hundreds of attributes
and then we would cluster them right and
so this would be the idea and so
nearby vectors there mean companies that
are similar uh at least in terms of the
attributes
it means they're probably kind of in the
same area
um they have about the same
capitalization
you know this kind of thing right that
they're they're they're just similar
and you could use this for lots and lots
of things um but in fact what would
appear when you do this
kind of automatically are financial
sectors right when you see companies
that cluster together
those would be considered that that's
typically called like a
financial sector or something okay so
these are the examples
we're going to come back to the
practical examples later because what
we're going to do now
is we're going to talk about actually
how to do clustering
actually it's a huge field you're going
to take an entire course on nothing
but how to do clustering but we're going
to show you a shockingly simple
algorithm that was one of the first and
it's still very widely used it or
actually
variations on what we're about what i'm
about to show you are actually
widely used right now okay
so the way this is going to work first
first of all notation and it's it's not
pretty but it's just
we have to be able to say to describe a
clustering and so we're going to
describe the clustering two different
ways
one way is we're going to give um we're
going to part we're going to take
so this this is set notation when you
see that squiggly bracket
that constructs a set and so this is a
set with n
elements and the elements are the
integers 1 2 3 up to capital n
those are the indices of our vectors
this symbol
means that g is a subset of those uh gj
and a subset means it is well it's just
what it sounds like it means that it is
a selection of some of the entries there
okay so for example uh okay
here's let's say we have i'll do
something really simple here
that's our that that is here capital n
is four so i have four vectors
um and then i could have two groups so i
would have something like this
g1 is one and four
and g2 is two
and three there okay so that's an
example of a clustering
i i put the first and last one together
and i put the middle two together and
that's my two groups okay
now we're also going to use
c sub i so c is a vector which is
capital n long and what we're going to
do is c
sub i is going to give you the group
that
x i is in so in this case
let's see so here c
1 is going to equal 1 and c
2 equals 2 right because this says that
entry item one is in group one
you can see that from here and so c one
is one c two equals two
uh c three equals three and c four
e whoa no no that is very wrong this is
two there you go
and one there we go sorry okay
so um yeah so these are this is how we
would these are two ways that we'll use
to describe
the clusters right um
uh now what we're going to do is we're
going to have group representatives
um and so these are vectors z1 through
zk remember we have k
groups and these vectors don't have to
be in our original data
in fact generally they are not they're
just arbitrary n
vectors and we're going to call them the
group representatives we're going to
later see what they are and actually
there's by the way by themselves it's
going to be super interesting but let's
just take
they're just group representatives okay
now the cluster
the best i mean a very good way to
actually kind of do anything
is to make it an optimization problem so
the way you do that
is you say what you're going to do is
you're going to write down
uh an objective function and in this
case
we're going to write down this objective
function i will
talk about it momentarily but then the
idea is we say
that if this is smaller if that
objective is smaller
we like that clustering better okay so
uh you should be very suspicious of
people who
tell you about something and launch into
a method before they tell you
what it is that would make them happy so
now i'm telling you
what would make us happy what makes us
happy is this
j-clust being small and so that way
there's no arguments right if
you come up with another algorithm and i
come up with an algorithm and we
evaluate our two clustering objectives
then whoever is smaller
is bet their their clustering is better
period
okay so this is kind of the approach in
fact it's the approach for a whole lot
of uh
of sort of you know mathematically
oriented methods and frankly it's
the correct approach right otherwise
things get weird and vague and
you'd say i don't like your clustering
it doesn't look good and they say yeah
well i don't like your clustering and so
on anyway so
fine all right so um
let's look at this clustering what it
this cluster objective so here's what it
is um what it does is it it it iterates
over all of the data and for each
each vector x i it finds
the distance squared to
its representative okay so that's the
zci
so that's that's so this is this is the
distance
without the square that's the distance
of item i
to its cluster representative so that
that's how that works
um and this says that we should take the
sum of the squares of those things and
then
we could divide by n so you get a mean
square uh clustering objective right
and so this is it so you know your job
here uh well here's your job your job is
to choose
the z1 through zk those are the cluster
representatives
uh and your other job is to choose if
you like the c's which is the same as
choosing the g's
so the c means you have to say for each
item which cluster are you in
so for item 22 are you in cluster one
two three four five
something like that so that this is
going to be your job is to do that
okay uh so that's this is the clustering
objective
and it's perfectly reasonable right
okay um so that's going to be our goal
is to choose a clustering and
representatives to minimize
uh this number and that's a that's how
we're going to when we we'll have an
algorithm that does this
and we're going to monitor our progress
by looking how how j cluster is
is it going down has it stopped
decreasing that sort of thing
and that's also how we're going to
compare two different methods for
example if we
if we try two different methods or uh
we'll well two different clustering
potential clusterings we'll judge
them by this objective okay
so we're going to now talk about the an
algorithm it's a very famous algorithm
it's actually very
very simple and yet very powerful
okay so here's the way it's going to
work um
so what we're going to do we're going to
solve the problem not all at once
remember our job is to find
the representatives and also the
assignments to clusters those are the
ci's
right so instead we're just going to
break it down
and and and try to figure out how to do
one
how to choose say the assignments if you
knew
the representatives and and then the
converse how would you choose the
representatives if you knew the
assignments
so we're going to start right now saying
suppose we knew the representatives
that's these c1 through ck so we're not
going to mess with them
they're just fixed and the question is
what assignment would
minimize the the cluster the j cluster
right and so
the answer is actually easy uh to figure
this out
um what happens is if you go back to the
cost here um you'll see that if we look
at
so z if i ask like how do i which
let's consider entry i
um ci appears nowhere else except that
one entry and so what it really says
is to make this as small as possible i
should choose
i should choose ci to be the index
corresponding
to the nearest neighbor of x i
in the representative set z1 through zk
so that's what i should do
okay so so that's the idea
um and that's it so we would say that
this way
you will assign each vector to its
nearest representative
by the way another way to say that is if
you haven't assigned
if you have not assigned a vector to its
nearest z then in fact
uh by assigning it to its nearest z we
can reduce
j klust or whatever the cluster
objective okay
so this is this makes perfect sense it
just perfect sense
okay now please note this does not solve
the problem this says
if you knew the rec if you knew the
representatives
the the the way to assign items to the
clusters
is to assign them to their nearest
neighbor among the representatives and
again that makes just perfect sense
okay now we're going to look at the
other
the other way around now suppose we fix
we fix the clusters that means every
vector has been assigned to a cluster
and then the question is how do you
choose now the representatives
to minimize our objective okay so in
this case what we can do
is the original objective is a sum over
one over n
but what we're going to of n items right
but what we're going to do is going to
reor
we're going to rearrange them and and
collect all the terms together that are
in each cluster
and so what it is is that the cluster
objective which is the mean square
mean square distance to your
representative we're going to write it
as a sum of
k different numbers and each of these
pertains only to cluster j so
let's look at this notation this says
that i should sum over x i minus zj
but i i'm only going to look at the one
the i that are in gj
that means that is the items which are
assigned to group
j okay so that's what this sum here
means
um and i put a one over n in in front of
it because
i got that from the original one okay
now then the question would be this
how do you choose let's say for example
zj well
zj only affects one of these which is
j sub j right and then it's this thing
and so we're left with the question how
do you
if i give you a set of vectors namely
the x i's that are in partition in
partition j
and gj group j then the question is how
do you choose a single number that
minimizes the mean square distance to
them
now that has a very simple answer said
very simple solution
which you know in the book we describe
how to work it out or whatever and it's
completely intuitive
it's the mean in other words if someone
says how do you find
a vector that minimizes the mean squared
distance to a set of other vectors you
simply average all those vectors
and that's that's the solution of that
problem okay so that says
zj is literally the representative is
the
average of the vectors in its group
makes per again
this is completely natural now i want to
point out that at this point
we have absolutely not solved the
problem because we've been asked to
optimize over both the partition and the
representatives
now oh we know how to do but at least we
know how to do we don't have to do two
things pretty well
if you fix the representatives we know
how to we know how to um
choose the clustering if we know the
clustering we know how to choose the
representatives and now we're into
something very famous in mathematics
algorithmic mathematics anyway uh when
you can't really solve the problem but
you can do what you you know how to
solve part of it if one thing is fixed
and
you know the converse right and that's
just called iteration
it's it's really it's it's pretty dumb
and
that gives us to brings us to a very
famous algorithm it's called k-means
it's actually from the 60s but like
actually like a lot of things when you
start looking the history goes back
older than that and the ideas were
certainly there all right so here's
here's the way it's going to work it's
very simple um we're going to alternate
between updating the partition
that means literally assign each item
to its cluster sorry two you assign
each item to the cluster which
corresponding to the closest
representative okay
then we're going to update the
representatives and to do that that's
simple we simply
for each group we are going to look
at we're going to set the representative
to be the average of that group
okay that's a famous algorithm and in
fact what happens is in every single
step
our objective goes down that's good
because it makes us happy when our
objective is small
and the reason is pretty clear right
that in the first step
when i assign each element if i if i
move an element if an element had been
in group three
if a vector had been in group three and
i move it to group 6 because the group 6
centroid is closer
my objective is going to go down same
for the same for this the other part the
second step
that if i update the representatives by
assigning them to be the mean
once again the objective goes down okay
so here's the algorithm here's here's
how we're going to write it
it says that we should simply update the
partition so you you find the nearest
neighbor
um and then you update the centroids and
what will happen is at some point um
you're going to get to the point where
the partition doesn't change and
thereafter nothing will ever happen
right that that's that's it in other
words uh every item
is assigned to its nearest neighbor
nearest neighbor among the
representatives
number one and number two each centroid
is the average
of its entries the entries in its group
okay
each sorry each uh each representative
or centroid i should say that the
centroid here
is an alternate alternate name for the
representative
or mean okay so and then when it stops
we just then we quit if the part
if the partition is the same on two you
know if the partition doesn't update
then there's nothing to do and we quit
because nothing's ever going to change
again
so that's the k-means algorithm very
famous algorithm oh
and notice that it to to understand this
you only need to know a very little bit
you know what a vector is and you know
what distance between two vectors is i
mean
it's not much okay
now let's see as i said the objective
goes down
every step uh until they stop changing
right
now one thing about this is
that you now you might think this would
actually solve the problem
um okay so now the fact is it does not
we will even see specific examples
where the algorithm stops and it is not
the optimal clustering
optimal clustering means that that
clustering
there's no clustering that has a and
choice of representation so it has a
lower objective
and we'll say that that's just not the
case
so it doesn't actually solve the problem
and so when you have an algorithm
that's not guaranteed to really fully
completely solve your problem
it's called a heuristic okay um
and uh there's many heuristics around
uh i mean honestly it's obviously better
to have an algorithm that solves a
that solves something exactly i mean of
course because
then you don't have to worry about it
there's no worry but there are many many
cases where basically we can't do that
and so we resort to heuristics and and
heuristics can be extremely powerful
and this is one of the cases where it
works very
very well okay okay
so one one fact about that is for
example
depending on how you initialize the
algorithm right you initialize it either
with some representatives or with an
assignment to
of assignment of items to clusters um
depending on how you do that that can
actually affect the final result okay
and what people do sometimes is they
they run k means like 10 times let's say
with different different initializations
they let it converge
and then among those 10 they just choose
the one that has the lowest value of j
cluster because that's kind of what
we're after okay so this that's that's
the idea
but it has to be remembered that
depending on how you initialize it you
can get different clusterings
okay so that's that's just the way this
works
okay we're going to look at an example
now the first one's going to be an
abstract example in fact it's the
example we started with
at the beginning of the lecture and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take this data
now of course this data it has is in is
two vectors and the right way to cluster
two vectors
is with your eyeball and draw okay but
we're just going to see how
we're going to walk through k means and
see how see what it does in this case
okay so here we go uh so we initialize
it
with these cluster
representatives okay i don't know why
but we did
okay there's just three three different
vectors the red
uh the red the blue and the green square
okay then what what's happened here is i
have
i have colored the points
according to their nearest neighbor
among those three
so if you're a green point like all
these guys are green down here
they're green because they are closest
they're closer to the green
centroid or representative than the red
or the blue
and up here this is just sad it's very
sad there's just two points that are
closer
closest to the red uh the red
representative than the blue or green
okay
now the next step you'll recall is we
now update the centroids and what that
means is or the representatives
that means that among all of these green
ones here
we're going to calculate the average and
that's going to be our updated
uh our updated representative for greens
and you know look
eyeball there something in the center
okay it's like right there
okay well okay here's where it is
exactly okay so that's
that that that's the that's the updated
uh green
centroid okay or representative all
right
the blue is gonna shift over to here and
you can see that that blue thing is kind
of in the center
of where the blue things are and okay
it's kind of pathetic there's
two points and the the average of the
two is the point right smack in the
middle
and so this red this sad little red box
here
uh is telling us it's it is it is now
the average of its two
uh it's two constituents okay that's
iteration one
uh that if you look at that that is a
pretty bad clustering right there but
the ones we're going to iterate so
that's iteration one
let's look at iteration two on the next
step things are getting a little more
reasonable because now what we do
is we go back and for every data point
we we fix the new centroids which are
here
here and here and we now go back and we
ask every point
which one are you nearest and then
that's your color
or that's your assignment group
assignment and
that we do that and now you see well we
got a big old group down here we've got
a few more reds
and then we update the centers and so
now the up these
these update this way and we keep going
okay
so um this is iteration three
um here's iteration ten and you can see
we're getting there
right so by now uh i mean it's still a
bit wrong right
you can see that these green things
morally should be
blue and so on this little bottom down
here morally should be red
and by morally i'm just joking it means
like our eyeball can see what the
clustering is
and but you know if you go like up to
iteration 15
the thing just stops and that's the
final clustering you get right
and so there it is and you know you
might quibble with it you might say oh
that green point maybe should be red
whatever
fine that the point is you know that
this is the final clustering
now of course uh to this is this is just
to walk you through
what it looks like uh what what what how
k means
works obviously the point of k-means is
not to cluster
two vectors because you can do that with
your eyeball and a pencil okay so that's
not the point
uh the point is this algorithm works in
dimension 10
and it works in dimension 100 or a
thousand or a million
right um if amazon
clusters their customers there's a whole
lot of customers and a whole lot of
items that they may have bought
uh last month right so you know these
are very very big problems
and this this the basically the exact
same algorithm
just runs okay so that's that's that
okay
all right
let's look at how this algorithm
converges
as as a function of iterations well uh
this is j clust and remember the whole
point of having an objective is so we
know when we're happier or not
right so um on the first step it goes
down
it kind of makes some little baby
progress and all of a sudden it goes
down here
and then this is this ends up being our
final uh clustering objective and it's
about whatever it is it's about
point uh i don't know 0.3 0.35 i don't
know
so so that's how k-means ran on this
this thing
and this is actually kind of typical